un possible lien entre la strazeele et
cas et la formation de caillots sanguins
c'est le verdict rendu par l' agence
européenne des médicaments lors d'une
visioconférence très attendu là même qui
suggère d'ajouter la formation de ces
thrombose à la liste de ce qu'elle
décrit comme de très rares effets
secondaires sans toutefois identifier un
facteur de risque spécifique sur la base
des résultats actuellement disponibles
des facteurs de risque spécifiques tels
que l'âge le sexe ou les antécédents
médicaux n'ont pas pu être confirmées
car les événements rares sont observées
à tous les âges aussi bien chez les
hommes que les femmes caisse un email
une explication plausible de ses effets
secondaires rares est une réponse
immunitaire au vaccin entraînant un état
similaire à celui observé chez les
patients traités à l'héparine sometimes
un vaccin efficace et qui sauvent des
vies pour la em qui précise que la
balance bénéfices risques est positive
même son de cloche du côté de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé qui
estime qu'un lien très rare entre le
vaccin et les caillots sanguins était
plausible mais non confirmée le royaume
uni lui recommande de limiter le vaccin
astrazeneca aux plus de 30 ans les
autorités sanitaires britanniques ont
précisé que sur 79 signalements de
caillots sanguins 19 personnes vaccinées
à l'astra zeneca était décédé en tout
plus de 20 millions de doses du vaccin
ont été administrées dans tout le
royaume en belgique suite au compte
rendu de l'agencé européenne des
médicaments
le ministère de la santé a déclaré
réservé le vaccin astrazeneca aux plus
de 55 ans dans la foulée l'union
européenne a déclaré appelé les 27 à
parler d'une seule voix pour ne pas
nourrir la défiance du public